good morning Wow y'all are awake nice so
my name is Kavya and I'm here today to
talk to you about using performance
modeling which is theory to use this to
analyze real world systems now why might
we wants to do this well ideally we care
about things like user experience so we
care about the response time of our
systems and ideally we want to give them
a good user experience without breaking
the bank
so we care about things like our systems
capacity and whether it's scales and so
as systems designers and builders and
performance engineers we spend many a
nights trying to answer questions like
this we can we have questions about our
systems performance how much additional
load can the system support what's the
impact of a change and optimization we
make how does it affect our end user
response time we have questions about
our systems capacity how many additional
servers do we need are we over
provisioned does this seem familiar how
many people here have spent many a night
trying to answer any questions like this
great just about everybody and so you
know there are a few standard approaches
we take to try and answer these
questions the first is what I like to
call the hashtag Yolo method
where you try something and cross your
fingers and hope it works we've all been
here no shame the second method is load
simulation where the idea is you
gradually apply a load with the goal of
stressing your system to empirically
determine its performance
characteristics and the bottlenecks now
I'm a huge believer of load testing so
we'll come back to this a few times
today but the focus of today's talk is
on the third approach which is
performance modeling now performance
modeling speaks to the idea of taking
your real world system representing it
as a theoretical model analyzing that
model and then applying those results
back to your system now the crucial
thing to know about performance modeling
is modeling by definition makes
assumptions about the system in the case
of the queuing theoretic models that
we're going to mostly look at today it
makes assumptions about the arrival rate
and the arrival distribution of your
requests it makes assumptions about the
order in which requests are processed
and assumptions about the service time
distribution now you're in order to use
a performance model and the results of a
model your system must satisfy those
underlying assumptions if it doesn't you
might still be able to leverage the
results in some way but you cannot apply
the model to it blindly okay so today
we're going to use performance modeling
to try and answer questions about our
system's performance and its capacity
specifically we will first look at a
single server system we will then talk
about a cluster of servers and then
finally we'll take a step back and see
what we can take away all right then
let's get started
so let's say we have a simple web server
single server system a simple web server
requests come in at some arrival rate
and then your web server processes them
then it might talk to downstream
services pretty straightforward now
questions we typically have about such a
system are what's the maximum throughput
of the server given a response time
target right we have an SLA what is the
maximum requests per second our server
can support while satisfying that SLA so
in this graph here we see at 4,500
requests per second we're still nice and
like below our SLA threshold and our
question is what about at 5,000 requests
per second what about at 10,000 requests
per second the second question we might
have about such a system is how can we
improve the average response time to
give our users a better experience now
we're going to use performance modeling
to study the system by modeling it as a
queueing system the way this works is
requests come in at some arrival rate
now when a request comes in if the
server is free the request is processed
but if the server is busy processing
other requests requests queue now the
time or request spends in the queue is
called the waiting time or the queuing
delay we're going to use the term
queuing delay today and then finally
when the server is free it picks off a
request from the queue and processes it
and the time the time taken to process
the request is called the service time
and then finally their response is sent
out now as you can see the response time
in this case
is simply the sum of the time the
request spends of a queue the queuing
delay plus the time spent being
processed the service time now we're
going to make three simplifying
assumptions about this system the first
is that requests are independent and
random that is they are not correlated
with each other they are not correlated
with the response time no they are
completely independent of one another
the second assumption is that requests
are processed in first-in first-out
order and one at a time so you can
imagine the server is a single is a
single core single threaded system and
finally we're going to assume that the
service time of requests is constant
that is to say the size of each requests
is the same and it's constant what this
in turn means we're assuming is that
there's no downstream saturation right
we're assuming that the network the
database nothing becomes the bottleneck
and this allows us to assume that the
service time is constant all right so
let's start with our first question
what's the maximum throughput of the
server well let's just use that queueing
model to try and reason about it
intuitively
now as the arrival rate the requests per
second entering the system increases the
server's utilization its busyness
increases right there's nothing
revolutionary about this it's like if
your boss shows up and gives you more
tasks to do you're going to spend a
larger fraction of your life of your of
your time being busy doing those tasks
but our question today is how does it
increase what is the relation between
the arrival rate and the utilization
and queuing theory tells us via the
utilization law formula that utilization
is equal to the arrival rate times the
service time that is to say the relation
between utilization and arrival rate is
linear it looks like a line okay
that makes sense so so what if the
busyness of our server increases well if
our servers busyness increases the
probability of an incoming request
finding the server busy increases right
so the probability that incoming
requests will have to queue increases
which means that the average queue
length increases right some make sense
and so this in turn means that the
average queuing delay the average time
of request spends in the queue increases
now again our question is well how does
it increase what is the relation between
the busyness of the server the
utilization and the queuing delay and
queueing Theory has an answer for that
as well and it captures it in the PK
formula know the PK formula has a full
form I think it's pronounced as the pulp
lockstep kin shine formula but I'm not
entirely sure so we're going to stick
with PK today and the PK formula tells
us that the mean queuing delay is equal
to this term that's dependent on the
utilization and these two other terms
that are dependent on the distribution
of the service time now we're going to
come back to those two terms later
because remember we assumed that service
time is constant so we don't have to
worry about those two terms right now so
looking at the first term only
we can say that the the average queuing
delay is directly proportional to that
first term right which is you over 1
minus u now what does this look like in
practice anybody know what that function
looks like it's a hockey stick right and
this is because as the utilization
increases that denominator goes to zero
so the entire fraction tends to infinity
okay so we have that relation between
queuing delay and utilization what does
this mean for a response time though
now remember response time is simply the
queuing delay plus the service time so
it's directly proportional to the
queuing delay so response time the
response time utilization graph looks
like that infamous hockey stick that we
all fear applying this back to our
question what's the maximum throughput
of the server
well when the arrival rate increases and
the the server gets busy its utilization
increases the mean queuing delay and so
the responses of the response time
increases and this response time
increase is not linear it's a hockey
stick so as long work as long as we're
in that low utilization regime
increasing the throughput increasing the
arrival rate means our response time
doesn't change a whole lot but the
moment we're in the high utilization
regime our response time is going to
shoot up right and the reason for this
is after our so after as we increase the
throughput after a certain point our
server is as busy as it
to be it can do mobile it can do no more
work so increasing the throughput only
means that request starts to queue right
so instead of throughput going up
response time increases does that make
sense okay cool so back to our question
what is the maximum throughput of the
server well in this case we see the
maximum throughput is about 5500 because
at that point our response time has
crossed that SLA threshold that we set
cool so that's our first question moving
on to our second question how can we
improve the average response time well
we saw that response time got worse as
queuing delay increased so can we just
prevent requests from queuing too long
basically control that request basically
control that queuing delay seems like a
reasonable idea in fact we already do
this in practice right when we set a
maximum queue length of any sort this is
basically what we're doing so the way
this works is requests come in if the
server is busy and the queue is full
requests are dropped so this prevents
the queue from getting too long and
queuing delay from increasing unbanded
Lee another way to do this is by
client-side concurrency control right
you have your clients observe when the
server is getting overloaded when
requests are taking longer to return for
example by setting the timeout and at
that point your clients back off this is
a form of circuit breaking there are a
few other things you can do here and I'd
like to touch upon two uncommon and
interesting approaches the first is is
this is this algorithm called controlled
delay now Facebook
men sit in their thrift RPC framework
the the key insight behind control delay
is that queues are mostly empty
you still need queues for reliability to
absorb bursts in traffic but they're
mostly empty and the way Codell control
delay uses this is it checks to see when
it checks to see when the last time the
queue was empty and if the queue was
last empty a long time in the past
it means requests have built up right it
means the server is overloaded because
the queue has not been emptied and at
that point it'll fill in queue requests
will still get and cute but they will
get em queued with a shorter with a
smaller timeout so they attend a timeout
faster so this is what the algorithm
looks like here we check to see when the
queue was last emptied if it was greater
than some time in the past then you set
a small unq it with a smaller timeout
does that make sense okay so that's
control delay a second uncommon approach
is to process requests in life--all
order rather than FIFO order now
Facebook's PHP runtime does this
adaptively that is queue start out as
being first in first out and when they
detect the server is getting overloaded
they switch to processing requests and
last and first that order and dropboxes
reverse proxy band-aid is always like oh
and the idea here the reason to do this
is that when the server is not
overloaded it really doesn't matter what
order you process requests in but if
assuming stateless requests of course
but when the server is overloaded it
makes sense to process the newest
requests first rather than the oldest
Quest's which have been sitting in the
queue for the longest and therefore are
more likely to time out there's no sense
in wasting your server resources on
those requests okay so at this point
we've talked about a few measures that
are somewhat reactive right and that
they intercept the queue length to
control queuing delay and slow response
time can we be more proactive yes we can
and for this we turn back to the PK
formula and this time we're looking at
those last two terms right the first
term the PK formula tells us that
queuing delay is has a linear dependency
on the average service time so by
decreasing the average service time we
can get better response time how might
we do this well we can optimize our
application code right
so this graph here for example shows us
that after you you make your request
handling function or whatever processing
you make that faster the though the
graph hockey sticks later so you can
support a higher maximum throughput and
your response time stays nice and low so
that's the first term the PK formula the
second term tells us that the queuing
delay has a quadratic dependency on
service time variability that is to say
the variance of your request service
times so if your requests are different
sizes and it takes in this high variance
and how long it takes to process them
then it's bad because there is more
queuing and so what you can do here for
example to
decrease this is you can batch your
requests right so here you have that's
the task says distribution before
batching and this correspondingly the
blue line and then if you batch them and
you keep your requests approximately the
same size your response time looks
better all right cool
so at this point we've successfully
applied of queueing theory modeling to
our web server single server system and
we've answered the two questions we had
about its maximum throughput and
improving its response time now question
do old single server systems look like
web servers no here's another example
say this time you are an IOT company ok
so you have some number of sensors out
in the field say their temperature
sensors that measure temperature and
periodically upload data to your
back-end system sitting in the cloud
now here's say the be the code on your
sensors might look like this they upload
a batch of data and they do this
synchronously so they send it to they
back-end they wait for an
acknowledgement and once they get that
response they sleep for some sleep time
this is to preserve power on these
low-power devices right so they sleep
for some time and then they wake up and
they upload the next batch of data ok
pretty simple now this question is can
we use the model we used to analyze the
web server can we use that model to
analyze this system what do you think no
and the reason we can't is because this
system
it differs from the previous system in
two important ways the first is requests
are synchronized right a client sends
its request waits for the response
before sending its next request and the
second difference that matters is that
we have a fixed number of clients we
have a fixed number of sensors out on
the field and so we need a model that
captures these two important properties
so the queuing theory model for such a
system looks like this right it captures
that feedback loop relation between the
response side and the request side of
our system and it captures the fact that
we have a fixed number and clients now
why does this matter though why do these
differences matter
well they matter in two important ways
the first is because requests are
synchronized the throughput depends on
response time right if you have if your
clients send the server some number of
requests and those requests start to
take longer so the response time
increases then those clients will be
sitting there waiting for their
responses to return before they send the
next request right so the throughput
decreases the relation here is inverse
as the response time goes up your
throughput decreases because of that
built-in negative feedback loop does
that make sense okay the second
important difference is that because we
have a fixed number of clients the
maximum queue length in this case
is bounded we have n clients and each
client can have at most one outstanding
requests to the server so your queue
length can be at most n so and if your
queue length is bounded in this case
your response time is bounded now in the
literature this is called a closed
system and as you can see it's super
different from the open system model we
looked at before so our question again
is well for such a system what is their
response time versus load what does that
graph look like what is that relation
and first things first the assumptions
we need to make or the simplifying
assumptions we will make the the first
is that the sleep time called the think
time in the literature that this is
constant that is to say all the sensors
they sleep for the same fixed amount of
time between requests as before we're
going to assume that requests are
processed in first in first order and
one at a time and that the service time
of requests is constant okay all right
so our question is response time versus
load right so in this system to increase
the load on the system we are going to
increase the number of clients ok
because when the number of clients
increases and each has one request the
number of requests to the server the
load on the server increases and like
earlier as the number of clients and so
the load increases throughput increases
up to a point
right as long as we're in the low
utilization regime after that once we're
in the high utilization regime
increasing the number of clients only
increases the queuing and so throughput
Troopa doesn't increase any more
throughput flatlines so that's what our
graph looks like
and our specific question is well what
happens to the response time for the
system in the high utilization regime
queueing theory tells us to use littles
law but before we get into littles law I
want to clarify I want to clarify the
model so we're all in the same page
about how this model works okay
now in this case the system is that
entire loop so requests can be thought
of as being in one of three states they
can be sleeping on the device they could
be waiting in the server's queue or they
could be being processed in the server
now the total number of requests is the
number of requests across all three
states and little flog gives us a
formula for that number the total number
of requests and this formula looks like
this littles law says that the number of
requests in the system is equal to the
throughput times the round-trip time of
a request across the whole system so the
time the request spends sleeping on the
device plus the response time now we're
assuming we're in the high utilization
regime so throughput is a constant we
also assumed that the sleep time is
constant so this simply becomes the
response the number of requests and the
system is simply a constant times the
response time right what does this graph
looks like of what does this graph look
like well it's a line right so in this
case the response time only grows
linearly with n applying this back to
our question
when we increase the number of clients
and we're in the low utilization regime
response time stays about the same and
once we're in the high utilization
regime response time grows linearly with
n so that in the graph so for a closed
system this is what the response time
number of clients graph looks like does
this make sense maybe cool okay now
notice that this is super different than
the corresponding graph for an open
system which looked like this right and
the high utilization regime that line is
not a line it's it's a curve that grows
like a hawk like a hockey stick okay so
at this point we've looked at open
systems and closed systems and how
they're different from one another so
it's it's hopefully obvious that we
shouldn't use a closed system model to
model an open system and vice versa
right there's only one problem does the
closed system model remind you of
anything like the load simulators you
might use to test your production
systems so the way load simulators work
right is that there's a fixed number of
virtual clients or virtual users that
you crank up between runs of your load
tests and they send requests to the
production system one at a time you can
in some systems you can configure a
sleep time between each client's
requests it's a closed system
but you're open but your production
system may not be a closed system okay
and this is important to keep in mind
because the you you can still use your
load simulation but you need to be aware
and wary of the differences right your
load simulation results might predict
lower response times than you've seen
your actual system close the systems
that tend to show better tolerance to
the variability or the variance and
request sizes closed systems and open
systems behave very differently under
different scheduling policies and there
are others and there are other
differences
is there anything we can do about it the
answer is yes the workarounds are
somewhat involved so we won't go into
the details today but if you have
questions talk to me later they're also
a couple of neat neat papers on the
subject that I encourage checking out if
you're interested
okay and with that we can now move from
single server systems to talking about a
cluster of servers because really our
production systems look like this now
questions we have about such systems
typically are to do with the capacity
right given we have this cluster what is
the or how many do we have this cluster
how many sir how many servers do we need
in that cluster to support a target
throughput another question we might
have is how can we improve how the
system scales that is to say as we
increase the number of servers of the
cluster how can we get better throughput
okay so let's start with the first
question
how many servers do we need well we know
the maximum throughput of a single
server system if we have a cluster of n
servers is the throughput of the cluster
just n times the single server
throughput I wish no systems don't scale
linearly so this is not the case and
systems don't stay linearly for two
reasons the first is what we can
attribute to a contention penalty okay
the idea here is that there's some
fraction of your workload that cannot be
parallelized
and that serial fraction of your
workload is not going to get any better
by adding more servers this is captured
and on dolls law as well and as and
in this case as you increase the number
of servers it's possible that there is
there's contention as well for shared
resources okay and this is captured by
this content by this notion of a
contention penalty and examples of this
is like for example trying to grab a
lock right and this contention penalty
can be levy it can be levied as some
constant times n and the idea here is
this penalty increases as the number of
servers increases which is what you'd
expect
the second reason systems don't scale
linearly is because of something we call
the crosstalk or consistency coherency
penalty that is if they have to if your
servers have to coordinate to keep
things consistent there's a penalty that
increases quadratically as the number of
servers increases okay an example here
is like SMP cash banging or servers
trying to coordinate to keep things
consistent
cool so where question is well
we know that our cluster might have to
pay these penalties this content in
contention and coherency penalty
what is its max throughput and the
literature tells us that we can figure
this out using the universal scalability
law now don't let the formula scare you
we can work through it intuitively and
it makes sense so the first line the
dashed line there is the the
sought-after linear scaling as the
cluster size increases throughput
increases linearly now the blue line
here is what throughput where the
throughput graph looks like if we have
to pay that contention penalty and
finally if we have to pay both both the
contention and the cross stock penalty
we see that the system doesn't scale
linearly or sub linearly it in fact
seems to scale or exhibit retrograde
scalability which apparently happens in
practice though it's kind of hard to
imagine when it does happen all right so
that's the u.s. cell and it gives us the
answer to our first question
now moving on to our second question
well how can we improve how the system
scales well the USL gives us the answer
to that as well
right the USL tells us that systems
don't scale linearly because of
contention and coordination crosstalk so
if we can reduce or eliminate sources of
contention and coordination our systems
will scale better and this is exactly
this is exactly what we do by by doing
things like using better data
partitioning schemes and better load
balancing schemes this is what we can do
by using smarter aggregation so school
bus time series data store you
an aggregation tree to aggregate results
of your time series query rather than
using a flat hierarchy because it means
you can paralyze things better you're
paying less if a contention penalty
other things you can do is you can use
more friend green locking you can use
MVCC etc all right so at this point
we've talked about single server systems
closed and open open versus closed and
we've talked about a cluster of servers
now it's time to take a step back and
ask the big question right where does
performance modeling fit into our
toolkit as performance engineers and in
my opinion performance modeling is most
useful and most powerful when used in
conjunction with empirical methods of
analysis like load simulation and
performance experiments and the reason
for this is because remember performance
modeling makes assumptions about the
system and it turns out to be to be
quite difficult to validate those
assumptions in practice right you need
to know things about your arrival and
service time distributions and it's hard
to get that data in practice but what
performance modeling does give us is a
rigorous framework to do a few things it
gives us a rigorous framework to
determine what experiments to run right
if you get the data to fit the USL curve
to fit the response time graphs those
are the experiments you want to run it
also gives us a rigorous framework to
interpret and evaluate the results so
for example if your load simulation
results look very different than your
production system
now you know why right or here's another
example say your load simulation gives
you a response time graph that flatlines
you know that that's not what your graph
should look like you know it should look
like one of the graphs on on the Left
right and the third thing is performance
modeling gives us a rear spring work to
decide which improvements give us the
biggest wins and we talked about a few
fees and with that it's time to say
goodbye thank you all for coming
if you have questions I'll be
[Applause]